the summer travel season officially
kicks off this weekend airports across
the country are already seeing a surge
of Travelers Chris Van Cleave shows us
what they can expect
the nation's busiest airport is about to
get a lot busier we are ready Atlanta's
Hartsfield-Jackson expects more than 2
million Flyers to pass through for
Memorial Day and Nationwide the TSA is
bracing for a potentially record-setting
summer we're ready first and foremost
TSA administrator David pakoski what's
different this year from last year this
year a big difference is we have more
staff I mean we're better staff this
year than we were last year during the
first three months of 2023 U.S Airlines
cancellation rate dropped below 2
percent far better than last summer when
Staffing and weather woes led to more
than 45 thousand cancellations we feel
good about the things that are within
United's control United Airlines CEO
Scott Kirby expects Memorial Day to be
the busiest in more than a decade Air
Traffic Control challenges are really
the number one concern for me as we head
into the summer and as we look to the
Future Airlines have already reduced
summer flying at the request of the FAA
on Sunday Air Traffic Control staffing
issues temporary rarely halted flights
at the busy Denver Airport this weekend
will be a test of the system Thursday
Friday and Monday are expected to be the
busiest travel days full flights can
mean not only a wait at airport
checkpoints but also in the parking
garages think about either planning
ahead or getting a ride to the airport
also if you can carry on it saves you
time when you get here and if there's a
problem it's a lot easier to get on
another flight all you have is a
carry-on already long lines met
Christina Jones missed her flight to
Orlando the next open seat was 24 hours
away I'm missing my job my kids my man
my house I want to go home get my bed
experts say budget at least two hours
for airport lines so your Memorial Day
isn't grounded before it can take off
for CBS mornings Chris Van Cleave
Atlanta